Catholic clergy abuse scandal includes
cases of abuse also by nuns CBS News has
reported on that issue over the past
month Niki batiste is in Rome with
survivors calls to expose abusive nuns
Niki good morning Nora good morning just
a little while ago here in Rome victims
advocates handed this letter to a global
organization representing nuns the
letter asked for predatory nuns to be
exposed so survivors can begin to heal
this call to action comes just as more
victims are speaking out I whipped
around I could not believe that somebody
was actually talking about it nun abuse
survivor Virginia June was at home in
Ann Arbor Michigan when she heard fellow
survivor Trish Cahill talking on CBS
this morning
pedophile nun is a phrase I think most
of our viewers will have never heard
it's the secret not yet told it was the
first time I actually was validated with
my story
facing a troubled childhood at home in
the Detroit suburb of Farmington Hills
June says she turned a sister PATCO wiki
for guidance
Kawika Todd Joon's religious studies
class at what was then Our Lady of Mercy
High School she seemed to be very
consoling and very nurturing and very
wonderful and she became a mentor to me
the 57 year old says sister Kovac he
began molesting her when she was 14
years old the first time was at Cole
wikiz apartment I knew it was wrong and
I didn't know who to tell I was so
confused it was like this sister is
doing these sexual things to me and I
thought she was married to God June says
the abuse continued for a decade and
fuelled her addiction to drugs and
alcohol she claims the school and the
Detroit archdiocese failed to act when
June and her family say they reported
the alleged abuse in the late 80s June
says sister PATCO wiki denied any
wrongdoing allegedly calling June
troubled she continued to teach at the
school until she died in 1994 in
response to June's allegations Mercy
High School says it is deeply saddened
and immediately contacted local police
and initiated an internal investigation
upon receiving our request for comment
in a statement the Archdiocese of
Detroit
tells CBS News investigating and
substantiating a 40-year old claim is a
matter that takes time and careful
consideration they added the complainant
deserves nothing less than to be
assisted and accompany on her journey
towards healing we think of nuns as
caregivers and maternal and loving last
month former nun Mary Dispenza revealed
to CBS News a nun allegedly forcibly
kissed her while she trained to join the
convent many years ago now working with
snapped the survivors Network of those
Abused by priests she is helping other
survivors tell their stories after our
first report aired in January nearly 40
people reported allegations of nun abuse
to snap that's an addition to at least
18 other reports the organization
received last year after Trish shared
her story and you shared your story with
us more victims found their voice and
reached they did and they're being
believed for the first time Dispenza is
in rome calling on the church to lay out
a plan to fight sex abuse we don't need
people praying for us we need actions
now sober for 31 years and married with
two sons June has a message for Catholic
leaders stop victimizing the victims
let's put the blame where the blame
needs to sit with the perpetrators
Virginia June says she believes there
are more victims of sister patco wiki
she says she's also glad the summit here
in Rome is happening and that it's a
start
but she said more work must be done to
protect children john nikki betis all
over the story since the beginning great
work nikki in rome you know it's worth
remembering that these abuses are so
awful and these people turn to priests
and nuns for peace and comfort and
solace in dark times and to then be met
with that is why this is just so
heartbreaking this is why the Pope needs
to do something immediately
zero tolerance and this send an
extremely strong message I hope that's
why some of these bishops are staying
behind and that it be sustained yes